um let's just get a situation reporter
and as you understand it the fighting is
going on right now in your country
you are reporting it quite clearly i
understand that what you see that's also
what we see and most of the cities you
are reporting from like mariupoli they
are totally under siege same was the
biggest second biggest city harkey it
was two million plus people and he was
about to be circled by russians who are
fighting we need some support which your
correspondence and the president of
ukraine yesterday was when he was
talking to parliament was making it
quite clear what we need we need to to
close the sky over us we need support by
military means we also need to financial
support to survive this very very
difficult ordeal and we want our people
to be in safety so these immigration
waves refugees are now coming through
our western border mostly to the nations
of slovakia hungary mostly poland
more than
million people crossed just yesterday so
there's a huge operation is going on
right now i mean let's pick up on each
of those points then the closing of the
skies you'll know nato says there's not
going to be a no-fly zone are you
thinking about some other way of trying
to make the airspace safer for
ukrainians to continue fighting the
russians because as you'll know a lot of
the fire power that's falling on
ukrainian cities coming from artillery
and uh multi-launch rocket systems so
perhaps fighting the russians off in the
sky will actually stop that
that's absolutely the way we see it all
the tacticals means you are talking
about they can be covered
if we have at least not superiority but
it's control over our skies we are
taking on different routes one is what
you just been described by having the uh
jets where we can operate our our pilots
are familiar with something which soviet
union produced and we used to use them
we have them in our now in our fleet
poland some other republics around
around ukraine they still have a
possession we can have a hold on them
something else is the anti-air missiles
we are talking about with our allies we
have our own but it's not enough to
withstand the pressure not just the
planes but helicopters and cruise
missiles which are bombarding our cities
right away we can also
imagine the limited operation over this
humanitarian crisis areas next to the
nuclear stations and the very people
across the millions of them are now very
vulnerable to against the attacks of
russians through the air if we can be
specific on some of your answers there
then so you still want to try and see
the ukrainian air force get nato uh held
ships mig-29s for your fight we need we
can use mix we can use suhoy's we would
be happy to use f-16s and on top of
we're just our pilots are not trained to
to work with them this is the difficulty
we have to overcome somehow so the best
the best that is the old older soviet
union types like mix and suhoy's
something else is that we will need the
support we'll need to retrain our people
it will take time
and do you have enough time because you
also mentioned no we don't have enough
time that's your very right but if you
have the anti-anti-air missiles for
example on top of our capabilities this
will allow us you know to operate much
you don't have to have a pilot you need
operator like for example this by
rectangles way using this uh the drones
something like drones yeah
and you said anti-aircraft i mean you've
got sort of shoulder launch missile
systems you've got your own ground
launch missile systems you're thinking
about patriots the thaad system like
what kind of system are you looking for
the patriot isn't very top of this food
chain is the very top of the line we
need something which will allow us this
man pass they will cover up to four
kilometers but most of the heavy bombers
operate at much higher altitude we'll
have something bigger than that and the
particularities are discussed right now
with bossier military as well yeah so
there are discussions to try and
increase the capability for surface to
enter absolutely
and on that capability then um
there is of course military assistance
coming in all the time
how concerned are you that the resupply
is going to become an issue soon
we are happy with what is coming and we
see that uh led by uk and u.s and some
other close allies the rest of the world
is coming to help some of the nations
which we wouldn't expect to to help
coming with the equipment we have to use
from you and we have to use we get from
the united states same same system which
we can use right now mostly anti-tank
which is extremely important hundreds
and hundreds of tanks being poured on
our soil so we have to deal with those
ones but some men parts as well
and you mentioned as well financial aid
what does that look like there's lots of
humanitarian financial aid going towards
ukraine are you talking about something
else more specific
some things like uh for example we are
now in in negotiations about generating
uh capacities russians started cutting
electricity sewerage water in our cities
you know sieging them in the sort of
middle-aged middle-aged ways we have to
get the generators to support the the
grid and that's something we need right
now but even to get this huge industrial
capacity generators in ukraine is
logistic operation by itself in the
middle of the war this is becoming
increasingly difficult to get there yeah
um mr striker you were in parliament
yesterday as your president was speaking
a rousing round of applause you know how
unusual it is for them to clap in
parliament but you guys do deserve that
applause i wonder if you've been able to
speak to president zelinski recently and
just can you tell us how he's how he's
holding up i i did i i told him about
the coverage unfortunately for technical
reasons he couldn't stay and then listen
to all the reactions in the parliament
so i had to explain to him that all the
parties not just the prime minister but
all the parties were united in support
of ukraine so much of the media coverage
young people were staying in the greens
next next to parliament covering the the
events he knows about this he feels it
at the whole ukrainian people they they
hear it they understand that the support
is here
so he's holding up and it's because
widely because of the support of
international support so he's he's
awareness passing on to ukrainian people
how you know the world is opening its
hearts and is rooting for ukraine to
come through this we see it even by the
hospitality which many nations are
extending to our people who had to get
in safety
mostly women and children are leaving
ukraine right now millions of them but
men are staying back home and fight
do you think britain's is doing enough
to bring in refugees
we we're going through i will see the
parliamentary and standing committee on
home and affairs just in an hour that's
the ongoing discussion the two of the
layers of the immediate ones already
done we're now talking about the third
certain package for ukrainians to be
invited with no particular uh connection
to families with no family and family
members this on this soil so you're
going to try and basically push for
almost like a an emergency visa if he's
away first we're we're working on it uh
this this sort of concerted effort with
european union with with the with uk uk
is a bit further for ukrainians they
wanted to be closer to the roots to the
to the nation they wanted to get back as
soon as it's possible so we are trying
to understand how we do it without you
know severe in this this uh connections
experience these roots and mr striker
let's talk about trying to end this well
of course there are going to be the
highest level talks i believe held
tomorrow in turkey between uh mr kubela
and miss kuleba and mr lavrov how
hopeful are you that those talks can
achieve something we're not putting too
much hopes on this particular class
we've been negotiating with them and
especially with there was minister
lavrov for many many years i was doing
this job before as foreign secretary so
i was doing my part of negotiation with
lavrov and in most of the cases he is
just you know the the facade of of the
putin's regime talking to the west
step you know there's been these talks
on the border we're going to speak to
someone who's part of that negotiation
process in belarus but you know the
foreign minister's meeting isn't that
well we are not talking for nothing we
hope that to get maximum out of it and
you're right we are having this
negotiation border but it's mostly about
the humanitarian corridors russians are
not allowing to move everything they
wanted their conditions to be met and
they're unrealistic and fair and
nobody's in ukraine is eager to do we
would rather fight and go with the
expectations of russians right now i
mean because you've mentioned those
conditions those conditions were put out
just a couple of days ago
is there anywhere in that the ukrainians
could accept to bring an end to this war
obviously the the idea is that you
become neutral you never join the eu
never join nato i can see from your face
that seems unthinkable but it would
perhaps end the war they also wanted to
read us to recognize that they snitched
the crimea out of our hands they also
wanted to be recognized both of these
runaway republics they recognized just
two weeks ago specifically to to make to
to to create even higher ground for
their own negotiations and they wanted
us to demilitarize meaning to laying
down weapons and moving from the borders
150 kilometers our armed forces leaving
kiev and harkevis post this is so
unrealistic that they do it on purpose
they're not expecting us to meet them
they're just creating this you know
informational sort of uh propaganda
campaign you feel entirely cynically
that this is not a it's quite cynical
absolutely
okay finally let's just talk about the
millions of people that have been
displaced in your country as you
mentioned that people don't want to go
too far away they want to come back but
of course the question at this point is
we've seen this one on day 14 and cities
being destroyed
what are they going to go back to after
this war is over that's a great question
and i've been frank with you we don't
have many answers right now what i can
tell you that over the eight years of
war already 1.8 million people were
displaced so we managed to absorb them
in a peaceful bigger ukraine and we are
the biggest nation by size in the
european continent so there is enough
place to start a new life there but you
know what to do with seven million
people now trying to get to the western
border is it just
serious serious threats to these people
all over this times that the hours and
and days trying to get there but then
what we do when we're already in a safe
poland hungary or slovak republic we are
very thankful for this hospitality but
we have to understand how we can settle
how our people can earn their living how
can they settle kids go to schools and
all these stuff the normal people
already have covered it now we face
something crisis with we never would
expect to happen in europe you know
we've read about this and seen on tv in
africa asia somewhere but never would
expect to have it in in 21st century in
europe